staying that ship if I were you baby
Yoda you are the cutest thing in the
entire universe we had no idea what to
expect from the Mandalorian but when we
saw exactly who the child was we were
hooked you are a 50 year old toddler and
there's still so much mystery about you
what is your species and what's your
real name
how are you already so good at using the
Force and most importantly could you be
any cuter what is it I got pet or
something yeah something like that
[Music]
the child aka baby Yoda is the latest
internet sensation and for good reason
it's hard to choose the cutest baby Yoda
moments but we tried keep watching for
the 10 sweetest moments from the
Mandalorian eating soup only baby Yoda
can make eating soup look so adorable
our hearts melted when we saw the little
guys sipping a bowl of soup in fact this
might be the most meme worthy scene of
the Mandalorian the screenshot has
circled the internet and is basically
the new kermit sipping tea mean just
look at him
can you imagine what he looks like when
he was younger and drink out of a bottle
walking through the woods whatever
species the child and Master Yoda are
from is a very special species Yoda was
short but extremely powerful the child
is absolutely tiny we love watching any
scene where he gets to walk he just sort
of waddles it's enough to make anyone
crack a smile you stay right here
you stay don't move understand when he
ignores mando and follows him through
the woods viewers tried to hide their
squeals but couldn't it was just too
much to handle
curious toddler it doesn't matter what
creature it is when babies are curious
it's so fun to watch from humans to
puppies you can see the Wonder in their
eyes baby Yoda takes it to the next
level after mando rescues him he floats
in his little pod he is taken in all of
his surroundings with Wonder he just
seems so excited and in all as his
little bed flies back to the ship in the
crib baby Yoda is super cute whenever he
is in his little pod bed but it was even
more adorable when he was in a real crib
even mando and the child stop in the
village when at the villagers has a baby
bed the way he stood and peered over the
side totally won over his new friends
and then the little girl feeds him that
made us fall in love with him
even more the force this green alien
species has to be super powerful Jedi's
most Jedi's have to Train long and hard
to master the force and then there's BAE
Yoda he is just a toddler he can't even
talk yet but he uses the force to save
mando and this was no simple task how
did he know what to do
plus we loved how exhausted it made him
sleepy baby Yoda is the best eating a
frog
he might be green but baby Yoda isn't a
frog but he is a big fan of eating them
we love when he sticks at frog his mouth
mando tells him this but instead he
slurps it down it was hilarious and
honestly where did that frog go it was
almost as big as baby Yoda himself Kili
mando the child is so precious that he
has even warmed mandos heart and the
little guy is very protective of his
tough Bounty Hunter he is obviously
upset when mando gets injured just look
at the wig he tries to heal him he
reaches his little green hand out and
it's so sweet the other kids he might be
a powerful future Jedi but he's still
just a kid well a fifty year old kid but
who's counting baby Yoda is a social guy
he loves meeting all the other kids in
the village they think he's just as cute
as the rest of us but you can tell he
feels so grown-up sitting with them
he looks so proud of himself he wasn't
there long but all the kids adored him
love at first sight we will never forget
the moment we first laid eyes on baby
Yoda we never expected a child to steal
our hearts but the second we saw him it
was love and is not just us the entire
Internet is obsessed so much so that
some have said they would use baby Groot
as firewood to keep baby Yoda warm in
this scene baby Yoda looks so small and
innocent in his little bed and mando
won't admit it but we're sure he was
smitten from that moment - who can blame
him pushing buttons just like every
other toddler baby Yoda can't help but
get into some trouble we love when he
pushes buttons on mando spaceship he is
pushing Manos figurative buttons - mando
tells him to stop stop touching things
but he pushes the button again he knew
exactly what he was doing but not even
mando can stay mad at mad yoda he's just
that cute if you can't get enough of all
these Ben's worthy TV shows you'll love
the things click the subscribe button
for more fun list and fan theories and
enable notifications - if you're
watching on your mobile check your
settings so you'll get notified whenever
a new video drops that's it for the 10
cutest baby Yoda moments who do you find
cuter baby Yoda baby Groot or baby
Grinch let us know in the comments
thanks for watching hit that thumbs up
button to show baby Yoda some love see
you next time